Bart Chilton has decades of experience
including distinction of being
knowledgeable about what people actually
do in trading let's first listen' on
speedy trading to Michael Lewis I would
trouble me and up Archie I agree it's
not against the law to leave the schmuck
and work for the other side that's what
people is a revolving door we haven't
anything about it we can argue about
whether that's a good thing or not but
leave that to one side here's what the
important point is creates this market
where high-frequency traders do not have
the speed advantage they can't they
can't exploit ordinary investors in the
way they can in the broader market in
the broader market hft high-frequency
traders are half half of all trades
maybe a little more the question is in a
fair market how what percentage of the
trades are they you know you eliminate
these advantages the opportunity to be a
predator whatever superior would and so
they don't disappear entirely so that's
the interesting thing is is happy now
high frequency traders but they level
the playing field and the answer is
about 20 percent I mean the i-x will
tell you the number so that gives you an
idea of the volume of trading that's
going on in the broader market it
probably shouldn't be going on
Michael Lewis soon as afterword goes
right after Bart Chilton he was gracious
to you in our discussion saying of
course you have every right to be a
lobbyist for free trade for the
high-frequency traders first of all who
do you represent let's start with who
Bart Chilton speaks for sure well first
of all not already astir lobbyists not
that there's anything wrong with this
fine what do you do I want to make this
I advise on strategy and tactics for a
group of high-frequency traders who call
themselves the modern markets initiative
mr. Lundie believe in what I believe
when I was a commissioner mr. Lewis's
distinction is the percent of trading
that is harming the market we're arguing
about 50% or 17% does he have a
justification to say that HFT is still
intruding unfair pricing absolutely not
h ft6ti lang very pricing the more
liquidity the smarter training that you
have the better price they're an element
that is harmful I don't think so I think
that my concern has always been as a
regulator and now and the Mardin modern
markets folks agree with me that we need
to ensure that there are appropriate
safeguards so the SEC just would you
support a delay in timing like I exhales
just simple as put it in a natural delay
or a geographic boundary that would
allow a level playing field to the
benefits of hft it's not it's something
that exchanges can certainly do and IEX
has done it and if that's their
marketing thing fine
but they still rely all of these
exchanges all the dark pools Tom they
rely upon hfts for liquidity and their
make Maurice Marjorie but why not have a
delay regulated by guys like you and
your old job that levels the playing
field so we get trust back in our
markets world it free free market and
people can do that and it wouldn't
necessarily be a bad thing for
oneexchange to do it or or another but
in germany for example they've talked
about slowing down two or three times
think about this though Tom it's not
just when everybody gets the information
its how quickly and how smartly they
react so I give you something and you
can you react quickly if you react wrong
that's not good for your business our
children your trooper to come on the
show